- [Commentator] Good
morning to you and "bore da"
from inside Caernarfon castle
where the preparations are now complete
for the arrival of Her Majesty
and of course the young man
who will one day succeed her.
(train engine roars)
It's a large turnout for the prince today
and the mood among the
gathering crowds is one
of anticipation, excitement
and, some might say, palpable tension.
- You're going to be fine.
(gentle dramatic music)
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheers)
- Charles!
Charles!
(crowd cheers)
- [Commentator] A good
response from the onlookers.
Only a few boos could be heard
and otherwise the Welsh people
showing enormous support.
(suspenseful music)
(crowd clapping)
- Two minutes, your Royal Highness.
(suspenseful music)
(dramatic music)
- I, Charles, Prince of Wales,
do become your liege man of life and limb
and of earthly worship
and faith and truth I will bear unto thee
to live and die against
all manner of folks.
- Shh!
(dramatic music)